what
is your calling
what is your north star
what is your purpose
what is your noble aim that is
transcendent
that maximizes human potential
that is pure that is in service
to god's love light
what is your calling
why is a civilization do we not hone in
on this for children
as they're growing up
what is the child's unique
reason for incarnating into
physical focus why
is the child here
what are they falling in love with
as they grow up
how do they feel
like they can optimally purely divinely
be in service to
the awakening the enlightenment the
prosperity the abundance
of the civilization
this has been really important
for me the last couple of weeks
obviously the idea of a transcendent
purpose north star noble aim
has been something that for
hundreds of years and especially
most recently what the psychological
literature has indicated is
extremely paramount for individuation
for you to focus on that
aim as your highest desire
and yet recently
within the last couple of weeks with
bentino massaro
at the shift into permanent alignment
retreat in costa rica
richard condon was also there and this
is also
a term used by anurag gupta
is the word calling and i really
resonate with the word
calling
again it's synonymous with north star
with purpose
transcendent noble aim these things that
have been talked about for hundreds of
years
in the psychological literature has
really focused in on
the last couple of decades this
transcendent
noble aim that you set as your highest
desire
and to do a process of self-authoring to
understand what that
is and to really hone in focus on that
so what we have is we have
we have a cool shot here that you're
looking at
we also have another shot where we can
more easily use this physical
easel and paper and marker and then we
have our classic
digital notes that we'll be going over
and you can find these
in the bio below so let's jump right in
the only
worthwhile thing to do is sacrifice your
life to your calling
your calling is the most important thing
you don't care about
this was also referenced by paul tillich
saying that the most important thing
for us to focus on none of us focus
on so stop
not focusing on your north star
start focusing exclusively on your
calling
full time
another way to say this is that there
are two ways of living
one of them is having lots of principles
directions
ideologies hobbies family goes on and on
until your deathbed regretting
your life bentino
made this joke at the retreat as well
think tony robbins does this exercise as
well
many of the greatest do this exercise
project yourself out to that deathbed
what will you have wanted to accomplish
right now in your
20s 30s 40s 50s what is the calling what
is the transcendent noble aim
so that you don't have that regret
because you were too distracted having a
million focuses
so that's why option number two is you
go all in
for one thing only all else will follow
in the wake of your calling
simple easy elegant no distractions
this is really critical
having a single single-minded focus
on that north star has been something
mission critical to me i had a lot of
commitments in 2021
that i recently reneged on so that i
could liberate myself
from what did no longer felt like my
highest excitement
following that breadcrumb trail of only
the highest excitement
is mission critical in a sense
you constantly have these options
in your trajectory of possibilities this
is
constantly pointing to your north star
to your highest possibility
and that you have to very carefully
analyze
all of your timelines and trajectories
and in a sense
dissolve all of these options so all
that is left is the highest
and so for me this option right here is
the one that i had to dissolve in 2021
so that i could focus on
only the highest
and so that revelation is really
important
it's wisdom gracefully lovingly step
back renege from your commitments that
no longer feel like your highest
excitement
to liberate yourself and open yourself
up to what feels like
only your highest only the calling
you no longer feel like you have all of
this
mixed frequencies happening but instead
it just feels
[Music]
just hyper aligned
so i'm going to go through my calling
and give you an idea of what that looks
like
and then i'm going to help you guys walk
through
a process of you identifying your
calling as well
and then we're going to go over other
examples of callings
so let's start things off with my
calling is people experiencing truth
this means people waking up to their
true nature
people realizing
that they are the one infinite creator
realizing that they are
that which endlessly creatively
expresses itself
with the absolute freedom
that is our true nature
and yet also realizing that they
are the absolute stillness
behind all of the creativity at the same
time
becoming aware of awareness becoming
aware that awareness is impersonal
shared and eternal
becoming aware of all as god's love
light
endlessly exploring blissfully
peacefully satchet ananda existence
consciousness bliss truth consciousness
bliss
and so a lot of this is about being a
jedi
and being able to navigate across
the different
levels of realization for certain people
it's going to be moving from being a
person
to becoming aware of their awareness
becoming more formless more subtle
becoming truly aware of the seer of the
observer of the witness
of awareness for other people it's going
to be
transcending that great i am
transcending
even the impersonal shared awareness
itself and realizing
the attributeless the agentless absolute
so people upgrading their scripts from
personhood to god
slash creator
leveling up in the video game slash
going super saiyan
this is typically what is felt like when
you move from being a person
you feel a more contracted
finite separate
energy and then
you liberate yourself into a more
expanded into a more
relaxed energy
when you move away from being a person
into becoming aware of awareness
and that's why it feels like you're
leveling up and then you become aware of
yourself as the creator you become aware
of yourself as the absolute it feels
like you're becoming super saiyan like
in dragon ball z
ah
and then you take that radiant
light love and then you bring that
with you to everything you do
that's what's meant by tantra you weave
your enlightened realizations into the
social fabric
or sahaja samadhi
and every single person is going to
undergo their own unique
taste their own unique style
of recognizing meaning that
every person like what the sufi
metaphysic
what that al-wujud means is the unity of
all finding
every person is going to go through
their own unique style
and taste of finding of recognizing
themselves
as god as the creator
that's why the quote of alan watts and
so many others
is many paths on this mountain but
there's only one
end
so some people are going to walk up a
little bit on this path take a little
bit of the signposts
retreats mystic teachings books
aphorisms from other paths everyone's
conceptual lattice work
around knowing themselves truly which
nobody can take away from you those
profound realizations
every single one of our realizations of
our findings of our recognizings
are unique they're a taste
and these unlock higher consciousness
as sri aurobindo and the mother mir
alfasa say
it's removing the rock that's covering
the
well of honey as rumi says
you go from room to room looking for the
diamond that's already around your neck
so you already have the well of honey
you already have the diamond
but there's this egoic contracted rock
energetically that's obsessed with
identity and form and personhood
that relaxes and expands
that contraction into the more
god state into the more higher
consciousness into the more creator
level gnosis becoming a gnostic
being
and so only radiant sunlight is left and
so this is key for me
for me it's people experiencing truth
people leveling up their consciousness
people
unleashing what
is currently frozen up as ice
through these stages into the formless
vapor
of god's love light
so it's mission critical for the shift
to become
irreversible so that's in many ways what
is meant
by this shift into permanent alignment
is that it's irreversible you've burned
all of these other trajectories you've
dissolved them
you've seen these timelines they no
longer serve you
and you've shifted into only the
absolute highest
towards that north star towards that
calling towards that transcendent aim
and purpose
and this is why you surrender your next
50 years until your death to your
calling and for me
it's surrendering my next 50 years to
truth
selflessly purely
to purify where i'm coming from where
each of us are coming from
so that i don't need to gratify some
sort of a
kink in my ego or in my attachment to
identity
to form this atlas unit doesn't need to
fulfill or gratify
any more of those kinks instead
it's solely coming from a place of
recognizing
you are the creator i am the creator
this is all god's love light interacting
therefore it comes from a place of pure
service to others
it comes from a place of just wanting
the other to experience themselves as
the creator to recognize their true
nature
but doing it from a place of having no
attachment to the outcome
doing it from a place to having no
attachment to the fruits
either you're gonna go and water
endless seeds
radiate endless light without asking for
anything in return without
ever planning to sit in the shade of
those trees
without ever planning to eat an apple
from the harvest
be that sunlight that endlessly radiates
light and love without ever expecting
anything in return
you're gonna have to deal with a lot of
not being seen
repeatedly
and that's the beauty of it is that you
become
so transcendently in service
purely in service blissfully joyfully
peacefully in
service because you know your true
nature
and you know the other's true nature and
you're
just in service wise
loving unified service
not excessively zealous or
martyrdom wisely
in service
you're a mirror
of god's love light purely
you're channeling that you're channeling
the sun
the sun is not expecting to eat the
fruits that's what's meant by karma yoga
we'll talk about that in a moment as
well so when you're devoted
everything [ __ ] off and all falls
perfectly into your wake
but this is key devoted that means
single-minded you're not undergoing that
other option where you have all of these
hobbies and
all of these ideologies and all of these
different things that you're focusing on
but you're just single-mindedly on your
calling
that's when everything [ __ ] off and all
falls perfectly into your wake
so for me it's also mission critical to
help those
that are in sto service to others
with this format and with global
enlightenment
so meaning this format of identifying
hey what is your calling
like playfully lovingly blissfully
joyfully peacefully
what's your calling
and see why we're doing this activity
you wake up every single morning knowing
yourself as the absolute you wake up
every single morning knowing that you
are the absolute perpetually selflessly
serving the absolute
without expecting any fruits in return
because you've identified your calling
this is why it's mission critical
hone in on this it will transform
your energy from a mixed bag of
frequencies
to something that's so divinely aligned
with god's love light
so my calling is also unleashing
people's callings
as you can tell that's been a massive
theme of simulation of this show
guys wake up unleash
your unique gift your unique firework
your unique purpose your unique calling
your unique north star unleash that
fully focus on that single-mindedly
you know subtly
that this is the honey this is that well
of
honey this is the diamond that's already
there
hone in become aware of the honey become
aware
of the diamond become aware of awareness
become aware of yourself as the absolute
become aware of god's love light become
aware of your gift
of your firework and hone in on that
single-mindedly
get rid of all the other mixed
frequencies
wisely distance yourself from the mixed
frequencies
it really feels like i've been doing
this across eons for infinity as my
soul angle each calling is like a unique
flower
aroma that's very much so
why we have these guests that come on
the program
the guests come on the program because
they're a unique flower
aroma they're sharing their calling
and more people get exposed to that
flower aroma and they're like
wow it's a beautiful flower aroma it's a
beautiful calling a beautiful firework a
beautiful gift and it's inspiring me
as well as the audience as the
interviewer
alright so
we have to disrupt our fundamental
axioms
in order to open ourselves up towards
the highest possibility
so
what i'm going to show you right now is
what it looks like
to take
what you thought was your world view
and to liberate yourself
into a higher level of consciousness
okay so
what we have
this in many ways is the diamond
on the left
and then on the right is your tree of
possibility
your trajectory space okay
most people what they think
is that they're open to this highest
pursuit in calling but they're not
they're only open to these they're
actually close to this because they're
close-minded
to it so you have to open yourself
up to the highest
because
that's where your north star is
so you have your north star you have
your calling
and it's up in that top right corner
and we talked about this a lot in high
level perception and chapter 2
seed theory
but in order to actually head up into
that direction
you have to see that these timelines no
longer serve you
this is where you normally go into
activities that don't challenge you
this is where you normally just chill
out
where you normally just watch a little
bit of netflix
or where you hang out with the same
group of friends that don't challenge
you
now what happens if you drop those
timelines
right and open yourself up to the
highest
timeline what is your calling what is
your north star becoming in service to
other people
truly recognizing your nature
as god's love light
this pursuit is not for everybody
but you have to know that it's an option
you have to know
that it's a possibility in your
trajectories and we're not taught in
school we're not taught by society
that there is this top
option that's available to us
normally we only see these options
go and get your little sheet of paper
for attending school
and then go and get the golden handcuffs
in the nine to five and the economic
machinery
shut up don't challenge civilizational
norms
consume propaganda consume
polarization geopolitically
and just be a slave to the economic
machine watch netflix eat lots of
fast food high fructose corn syrup
and so liberate yourself towards
this highest path
this is only open to those
that are truly seeking their calling
that are truly here in a transcendent
way that are not here to subscribe to
the matrix
that are not here to subscribe to just
being a slave in the economic machinery
that are not here just toiling endlessly
in suffering
because they have no interest to become
sovereign masters of their energy
of their mind-body spirit complex
you can become a master of that
but this is where you have to follow
many of the mystic traditions
you have to become aware of awareness
itself
you have to become aware of the sky that
is eternal and impersonal that has all
these little clouds
appear and disappear and no longer get
attached to those clouds
recognize this pause use the breath as a
tool
to sink into the stillness the peace and
the joy
the very [ __ ] ananda that has been
talked about for millions of years
and so for thousands of years for
millennia
and so this has to be burned this has to
be dissolved for those that
truly seek their calling
their north star the absolute highest
timeline
for themselves to be in perpetual
service to others purely
divinely selflessly in god's love light
alright
so in many ways you have to sacrifice
the person into the black hole
that in itself is scary
for most people because they are so
attached
to their identity they're so attached to
the form
and it's addicting because
you lose your costume
it gets zapped like a moth in the white
source light when you commune with your
true nature
when you commune with infinity you no
longer associate yourself with your
identity and with your form and with
your costume
but you associate yourself permanently
as infinity endlessly expressing itself
as both everything and nothing and
beyond that
and now occasionally you'll come into
the physical focus when somebody says
hey atlas will you
pass me the microphone yeah yeah you
know you come into that space but now
you know
your true nature
and so people don't want to sacrifice
the person into the black hole because
they've become so attached
but our highest calling requires us to
sacrifice the person into the black hole
and to align ourselves with god's love
light
and so another way to ask yourself about
what your calling is
is simply i want to do this
for other people what is your this what
do
you want to do for other people
do you want to help them experience
truth do you want to help them
experience
love do you want to help them become
awareness to help them recognize
themselves
as the creator do you want to help
maximize human potential do you want to
help people gain access to clean water
and clean food and sustainable forms of
energy
there's an endless amount of
ways for you to do
something for other people if your
calling has to do with you it's an ego
trip
really important to remember that
calling equals highest excitement with
no attachment to fruits that's what's
meant by karma yoga
so follow that breadcrumb trail of your
highest excitement as bashar says
until you can't go any further without
expecting
anything in return
no attachment to the fruits whatsoever
again been practiced for thousands of
years karma yoga
purify where you're coming from focusing
on
the roots not the fruits but the roots
where
are you coming from all right let's go
through
the process together
for you all so
let's reflect inward on an
archaeological excavation
of our calling
so this is going to be the north star in
the labyrinth of your own creation so
you
are the one that put your own north star
your own
calling into this labyrinth of your own
creation
so now you are playing the game you are
hiding right now
and you're seeking what your north star
or your calling is
okay you programmed your north star
you're calling into this game for
yourself
and now you're remembering what that is
so look for experiences that reveal your
calling
what has made you light up like the sun
inspiration is trustworthy locate your
calling in the most powerful experience
of your life
this is most real make the word
encompass as much of the experience as
possible
so reflect back on these experiences
when have you
lit up like the sun
when did you feel transcendent in that
peace and that
joy what were you doing for other people
how were you helping other people how
are you serving other people
when you lit up radiantly like the sun
and package that down into a word
as best as you can
and then you'll go through the format of
my calling is
people blank
that word
my calling is people experiencing love
maybe that was when you felt most
radiant
when you were in service to other people
and they felt
like you were selflessly loving them
and maybe now you want that god's love
to be shared with everybody
so look in the most powerful experience
of your life
calling is what you are it's just
obscured
calling is the intention that brought
you to physical focus
calling is the most important thing in
your life
again that we don't focus on calling is
the context for your life
calling is your frequency your quality
of consciousness
raw power pure energy calling creates a
better world
honor is giving something your highest
regard promise to fulfill your calling
in service to global enlightenment
so again what brought you to physical
focus what
brought you into this incarnation why
are you here
what is your calling your purpose your
north star why are you here
it's obscured by your mixed frequencies
align that with just god's love light
shatter the mixed bag of frequencies by
just single-mindedly focusing
on the highest your unique gift your
unique firework
calling north star noble aim that's
transcendent and in service to others
that creates a better world
that maximizes human potential that
solves the sustainable development goals
that's in service to global
enlightenment
what calling north star noble
transcendent aim is worth me giving my
life to
you're giving your whole life to this
50 years you're gonna give to this
and of course over time it will iterate
your calling
so don't become obsessed with a word
but at least put it in that north star
transcendent noble aim position
have a calling
if you can't fulfill your calling i
wouldn't go to battle with you
many of these statements are from
richard condon and from bentino massaro
from their time together at the shift
into permanent alignment
they have been doing this for a long
time with onorag
and working with different leaders
around the world
helping them with
this calling and with purifying where
they're coming from
so they're not coming from a place of
ego trying to extract
peace and happiness from the world but
rather they're bringing
peace and happiness to the world
calling is your deepest resonance it's
the password to the computer
that you align yourself to capturing the
essence
nature of your calling calling is the
background nectar of your terrestrial
life
calling is where you're coming from
the more simple and elegant the more
powerful
so i would highly recommend you to do an
activity
and we'll go through these examples here
but i highly recommend you to go through
the activity
of writing out what you feel like
are your calling you can do one option
you can do five or ten
options and then play with them over the
span of a couple of days reflecting on
them
what feels like it's most like your
calling
reflect on those experiences that have
most profoundly
felt true to you as you're calling
let's go through some of the examples of
callings
these are really helpful because they
give you an idea
of what can be thought of as these
transcendent
noble aims north star's purpose calling
in service to others purely people
giving themselves
fully the truth people living wisdom
people knowing they're already home
people lighting up people going all in
for the moonshot
people being touched by god's love
people being limitless
choice people experiencing an open heart
people being
pure love people experiencing
freedom people being illuminated
people experiencing themselves as the
creator people knowing they
are the source of love people are
inspired
people experiencing divine love people
gathering their will
people resting in the radiant ease of
being
people igniting pure heart radiance
people experiencing enlightenment people
following their highest excitement
people embracing the power and innocence
of divine energy
people realizing themselves as
miraculous
people experiencing radiating brilliance
people raising the vibration of humanity
people being inspired as [ __ ] people
experiencing infinite possibilities
people manifesting their missions
businesses coming from source people
experiencing bliss
people experiencing ultimate freedom
people experiencing
anything is possible people realizing
joy is a higher form of love
endless possibilities with callings i
hope
this catalog this palette
gives you a deeper idea of the
possibility space
for the profundity of callings that are
transcendent that are noble
that are aligned with god's love light
in pure
service to others
so go through that exercise around your
calling
again it's literally the only worthwhile
thing to do is to sacrifice your life to
your calling
and it's currently obscured by this
mixed bag of frequencies
so in order to detangle that
slow yourself down
slow down the fluctuations of mind
use the breath as a tool
and turn inward
what am i who am i what is
i might that i
be shared might that i be eternal might
that i
be infinite might this creation just be
one expression
for that observer that is shared an
eternal to experience
and might i be the creator of the
observer and of the experience
reflect on that and reflect on what your
calling is
what is your unique
reason for incarnation for physical
focus
what is your gift what is your firework
what lights you
up what makes you feel like the radiant
sun
of god's love light
reflect on that and write about it
make options for yourself
untangle that mixed bag of frequencies
and then put the calling in the north
star position
and hold it there permanently and
reneg on all of these other
commitments mixed frequencies
make declarations constitute yourself
in your calling
away from all of the noise
i will perpetually selflessly purify
myself
in focus to my calling and i will
not focus on the mixed frequencies
that are constantly civilizationally
propagandaly
pulling at my energy system trying to
distract me
have that high level of vigilance and
discernment
and reflect on this
frequently on your true nature abide
as the creator of awareness
and of these realities
abide as your calling
what is your calling what is your
purpose what is your north star
what is your transcendent noble aim
hone in on that hone in on that
dissolve these timelines
that are lower and no longer serve you
and pursue
the absolute highest trajectory for
yourself
for your family for your friends for
your community and for the world
you're calling your north star
your transcendent noble aim your purpose
hone in on this
it's the only thing worthwhile doing
sacrificing your life to this
thanks everyone for tuning in infinite
love
i hope the video brought you tremendous
value
again i'm really grateful to bentino to
richer to honorable to the whole team
for putting together the alchemical
container that they did
at the shift into permanent alignment
retreat in costa rica
this is mission critical the word
calling
it's mission critical so wake up to it
if the video brought you value give it a
like helps the youtube algorithm
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
yet also if the video brought you
value share the video with other people
that you know
it would also bring value to remember
the salience the importance the
poignancy of the word calling and of
this practice
of identifying what yours is and
single-mindedly
honing in on that comment below with
what you're calling is
we would love to hear from you let us
know what you're calling us it'd be a
lot of fun to have the community
talking in the comments
and any other comments around the show
would love to hear from you down there
that's all infinite love
abide as the creator
abide as the absolute
you are the highest i assure you
abide as your calling
maximize human potential
huh
you